Russia is threatening to pull out of its
grain deal with Ukraine on Thursday
unless the list of its demands are met
it's allowed million tons of Ukrainian
grain to be shipped via the Black Sea
ports blockaded by Russian forces now if
the deal collapses it will be a further
blow to Ukrainian Farmers Natasha
Butler's this report from Western
Ukraine
spring in Western Ukraine this young
wheat will be ready to harvest in two
months but Farmers here worry they won't
be able to sell it because the war has
severely disrupted exports
Alina's family has owned this farm for
decades she says Russia's blockade of
Black Sea ports a new import
restrictions in some EU countries are
hampering trade
since the port blockades we've not been
able to send by sea so we started
exporting via our western border to
Poland and Hungary but now they've
banned our grains so our trucks have to
carry our products all the way to Italy
Poland Hungary and three other countries
recently banned Imports of Ukrainian
grain to prevent a glut although the
grain can still Transit through them
it's forced this Farm to find new
clients further afield but Logistics are
pushing up costs and not being able to
export easily means millions of dollars
worth of grain could be lost
usually at this time of year all of the
Grain on this farm would have been sold
but because of the war and all the
problems linked to it half of last
year's Harvest is still here having to
be stocked in the silos and in these
huge plastic sleeves
a few kilometers from Poland's border
this rail Transport company is trying to
get things moving we have here European
wagons which are already loaded with the
Ukrainian grain and it's ready for
transit to the Polish Port of Dansk for
the manager says the wars changed
everything they didn't transport grain
before The Invasion now it accounts for
50 percent of the business we had a lot
of requests to support Ukrainian Farmers
for export there grains into Europe and
from that moment we started to construct
the new Grain Terminal
as one of the world's main grain
producers Ukraine's exports are
essential for its economy and to feed
people around the world
Valeri says transporting it at such a
vital time isn't just about supporting
the war effort it's also a way to build
more connections with the European Union
the Kiev is on track to join one day
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera sofkiewsky
Western Ukraine
authorities in Ukraine have detained the
head of the Supreme Court in a
high-level corruption probe a Ukrainian
MP says sevillaud niazev was detained in
connection with the bribe of nearly
three million dollars the country's
anti-corruption Watchdog says it's
exposed large-scale foul play at the
court it shared a photograph of cash to
illustrate what it calls corruption at
the highest levels of power
South Africa's President says six
African countries will send a peace
mission to Ukraine and Russia as soon as
possible they'll be meeting with
presidents of Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir zielinski to discuss a possible
plan to end the war Nicholas hack
reports from Dhaka
a peace initiative by six African
nations mediating an end to the war in
Ukraine the announcement was made by
South African president Syria ramaphosa
the two leaders that I had occasioned to
speak to that is President Putin and
president zielinski
agreed that they would be willing to
receive the mission of the African heads
of states in both Moscow and Kiev
despite pressure from Western countries
most African countries have abstained
from voting on resolutions at the U.N
security Council condemning Russia's
invasion of Ukraine meanwhile Russia has
been building close economic and
Military ties with States in Africa
since the War Began
I believe Ukraine really needs to take
steps forward to meet the countries of
the African continent we didn't work
well for many years we didn't pay
attention I think it's a big mistake
Ukraine is one of the biggest exporters
of wheat to Africa Russia is one of the
largest exporters of fertilizer to the
continent since the war broke out food
prices in Africa have shot up spreading
widespread discontent in Africa the U.N
warns 220 million people could face
hunger with bread becoming unaffordable
to many
very devastating for African countries
because their own resilience you know
it's not it's not as strong as other
countries in other parts of the world so
I think if we consider these factors we
can see why African countries want to be
very much actively engaged in the
political process but many are
questioning whether the African Peace
initiative can succeed when others have
failed the heads of state of Zambia
Senegal the Republic of Congo Uganda
Egypt and South Africa are set to meet
with the two leaders as soon as possible
at stake is not just peace in Europe but
saving lives of many Africans Nicholas
Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar